جهاد النكاح،
عند سماع هذه الكلمة
فإن الأذهان تذهب مباشرة
نحو الدولة الإسلامية وداعش وطالبان،
والكثير من الحركات المرتبطة بالإسلام
بطريقة أو بأخرى،
وهذه الكلمة مقرونة بالإرهاب لدى العالم الغربي،
لكن من أين جاء هذا المصطلح وما علاقة اليهودية به؟
وهل دعى الإسلام لهذه الأشياء؟
في الوقت الذي لا زالت الدنيا تقوم ولا تقعد
ومنظمات حقوق الانسان ووسائل الإعلام،
لقد سخروا كل الوسائل
للتنديد بجهاد النكاح فما هو أصله
وكيف جعله الغرب صناعة إسلامية؟
هو حديث الإعلام العربي خصوصا والعالمي عموما،
وهو ما ربطته الدول الغربية ومنظمات حقوق الإنسان
بداعش وتنظيم الدولة والعديد من الحركات الإسلامية، ...
أما في البعيد قليلا،
وخلال المعارك الإسلامية في عهد الرسول محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
وعهد أصحابه وأتباعه، كان في ذلك العصر
الكثير من المعارك، والغزوات والفتوحات، الرومان، والفرس
والصليبيين فكانت النساء تسبى،
وكان هنالك ما يسمى بملك اليمين،
لكن لم يسبق يوما أن سمعنا أنهم كانوا يدعون إلى شيء يدعى
جهاد النكاح الذي انتشر اليوم كالنار في الهشيم،
وليس إلا محاولة من الدول الغربية وإسرائيل لتشويه الإسلام والمسلمين،
وذاع صيت مصطلح جهاد النكاح خلال أحداث ٢٠١١ في سوريا،
لكن بالعودة لأصل الموضوع فجهاد النكاح عبارة عن
مصطلح كان اليهود هم السباقين لاستعماله،
بينما الفتوى عند المسلمين يقابلها كلام الحاخام لدى اليهود،
والحاخامات اليهود كانوا قد أصدروا فتواهم بوجوب جهاد النكاح على الإسرائيليات،
لتجنيد واستدراج من يريدون من الساسيين، حول العالم،
في المقابل يجري تهديدهم بصور تؤخذ خلال عملية
ما يسمونها بجهاد النكاح، ومن هنا بدأت الحقيقة تتجلى رويدا رويدا
عن علاقة اليهود بهذا المصطلح،
إذا فاليهود جندوا النساء لجهاد النكاح أولا،
ودسوا السم في العسل، للكثير من القيادات العربية،
خلال السنوات الأخيرة كشف موقع إسرائيلي عن أخطر سلاح
يستخدمه الموساد، ألا وهو جسد المرأة،
واعتبر الموساد أن جسد المرأة هو أهم أداة لتحقيق
أهداف دولة الاحتلال الصهيونية،
مستندين بذلك إلى فتوى حاخاماتهم،
فتم إعطاء المرأة الحرية المطلقة للتصرف بجسدها كيف تشاء
ومع من شاءت، شرط أن تكون العملية في خدمة دولتهم المزعومة،
ولأجل خدمة الدولة، فقد قامت وزيرة خارجية إسرائيل
(تسيبي ليفني) بالاعتراف أنها مارست الجنس مع العديد من الساسيين
حول العالم، ليس هذا وحسب حتى أنها تتهم بعض الساسيين العرب،
ومن أشهرهم ٢ من كبار القادة الفلسطينيين،
وهما صائب عريقات وياسر عبد ربه الذين هددتهما
إذا أنكروا علاقتهم بها، بأنها ستنشر صورهما وهما عاريان،
حتى أنها هددت أيضا كل من وقع في شباكها
أنه إن لم يعمل في خدمة دولة الاحتلال
فهي سوف تنشر فضائحهم بالصوت والصورة،
يصف الجيش الإسرائيلي
المتطوعات لعملية جهاد النكاح الخاصة به بالبطلات،
ولازال يغدق عليهن بالأموال، ليكسب رضاهن،
فيما يعرض عليهن الكتب الدينية القديمة والمحرفة،
ليعرض قصص نساء خدمن دولتهن بذات الطريقة،
وكانت أحد الإغرآت، تعيين عيلزا ماجين كنائبة لرئيس الموساد،
وهي المرة الأولى التي تعين امرأة في منصب كهذا في إسرائيل،
وهكذا فإن أصل مصطلح جهاد النكاح نابع من اليهود أنفسهم،
فقرروا استخدامه ضد الدول الإسلامية،
وقد وصلوا غايتهم، لكن لابد للحق أن يظهر
وينقشع الضباب الذي غطوا به على أعين العالم،،
والآن ما رأيكم أنتم متابعونا هل كان المصطلح صناعة يهودية، أم إسلامية؟